you can't always see the changes that
coronavirus is making to the way we will
be living our lives at first glance
everything might seem normal but what
even is normal anymore since you believe
there will ever be a return to life as
it was pre-pandemic a new poll for Sky
News by YouGov found only 27 percent of
people think life will be much the same
as it was before
well far more 59 percent said it will be
significantly different
we like normal and if something works we
just repeat and the fact that there is
this kind of a disruptive environment
has given us time to think and adapt and
I think we've done it beautifully to be
honest I don't think we're going to go
back to a world that looked the same
people will be more guarded in their in
their approach towards strangers there
may be more caring towards strangers as
well and I think that there will be
shopping alertness
so what does that mean for Europe's
busiest shopping street or at least it
was potentially facing an existential
crisis but what do people want well the
message is bleak for the high street 39%
of people we surveyed think they'll go
back to shopping in stores while almost
half 49% said they'll continue online
when everything goes back to normal I
don't think I'll rush straight away
because everyone gonna be rushing I fall
out I'll still be online for a while my
heaven stay online it just depends I
fall out when you shop online things are
cheaper anyway I think what will happen
is that I will probably for more
important things like clothes yeah I
think I'll for me you're doing a lot
more shopping online but the grocery so
though I think I'll still be going out
this all might be part of a trend to
stay at home or with the future of the
daily commute also in doubt 40% of those
we are said they'd return to commuting
back to the workplace while 47% said
they'll continue from home companies
will realize they don't need to maintain
massive office complexes and that most
of most of their staff can actually work
from home so there won't be the demand
for off his face
where you spend your time changes who
you spend your time with 37% claim
lockdown brought them closer to their
partner do you think actually there been
any personal upsides for you in the
pandemic in the way they're searching my
family I appreciate my friends I
appreciate simple things and what I
think I've taken from it is that we
don't need as much we don't need to rush
you around as much and enjoying the
amazing weather coronavirus has been a
devastating experience for so many in
society but collectively the experience
of lockdown has provided some glimpses
for people of what could be done better
is now a moment for a shake-up that
means the country and the globe could do
things better in future knock down has
meant a lot less of this pollutant of
all forms breathing in pure air is
popular it turns out I think a lot of
people have started to appreciate the
outside spaces a lot well also I think I
don't know people that start to see how
nature is reacting to us not being
around which is fantastic it's kind of
like almost the start of a blueprint of
a new future many agree asked to pick
the top issue facing the globe 33%
selected climate change in the
environment this is more than twice as
many who think preventing future
pandemics is a priority selected by 15
percent of people meanwhile just three
percent chose terrorism despite its
dominance in the early years of this
century we spent lockdown dreaming of a
more a Dilla k-- future but the truth is
we won't be able to stay afloat without
emergency support for some time to come
Sam Cote Sky News